the jurgen experience
i learned about the adaptive reason for
psychopaths being in society so you'd
think like it's about one percent nor
point one percent to one percent of
people are psychopathic right and then
you can filter that down to the ones
that have got sufficient uh motivation
to actually go and do something that's a
bit wild but i was asking this guy the
researcher and i was saying look
what is it how do psychopaths even exist
like why do they exist i can't
understand why they're adaptive i know
that you can be effective over short
periods as a psychopath but over long
periods of time it doesn't end up being
very good for society and i thought it
would have been bred out he said yeah
you're right except for the fact that
over the entire size of a population a
few psychopaths actually make sense if
you're a raiding party a viking raiding
party that needs to go over and [ __ ]
everybody up in lindisfarne which is
near to where i lived in the uk
you want some psychopaths you don't want
them to come back with ptsd you want
them to go over there burn everything
down rape the women pillage come back
with gold and supplies and grain and
whatever else they take and not care
about it you actually
on an individual level psychopathy might
not be fantastic for the people around
them but in a tribe
it's actually quite adaptive and quite
useful it's like a weapon like a very
specific sort of weapon that you can use
yeah break glass in case of war yes yes
in case of raiding party it makes sense
that it would be sort of a a legacy
thing
that
exists in the human population that
we've had it because it was very
beneficial thousands of years ago but
the difference is difference is now that
you're not going to get pulled up as
much for being a psychopath because you
can move from town to town if it was a
dunbar number of 100 or 150 or something
in your tribe previously we're gonna do
go to the next tribe maybe maybe maybe
that would have happened i don't know
perhaps you could move from one tribe to
another tribe it seems pretty unlikely
you'd probably just get killed but if
you [ __ ] over people one too many times
this is the reason that socially we're
so
careful of status it's one of the
reasons why we are concerned about
public speaking because one of the few
times you would have done that is when
your status would have been in um high
focus and people might have said if this
goes badly they're going to drop down or
maybe you were defending yourself
against the tribe of some kind right
if you're not able to move on
that would make psychopathy more
difficult to manage and more likely to
be punished i think but now you can just
go from town to town to within a city
you go from suburb to suburb change your
name not use your social media profile
anymore i think that psychopathy people
that are actively
being psychopaths are significantly
easier now to hide in amongst society
that makes sense it also makes sense
that psychopathy would have been more
common because it would have been more
useful when you're constantly in tribal
war correct yeah it depends on how you
deploy it so it's interesting
psychopathy to be a clinically diagnosed
psychopath you actually have to have
committed criminal acts
so you can't be
because of the way that the the current
um psychopathic checklist is called i
think you have to be 28 out of 40 in the
uk or 30 out of 40 in the u.s the u.s
has got a higher threshold for
psychopaths which is kind of funny
and um
there was this guy this research who's
researching psychopaths and what you see
is a particular area of the brain is
down regulated right so you don't see as
much activity when you see stuff like
death or images that would cause you to
have empathy so he decides that he's
going to study a bunch of psychopaths
many of whom i think are actually in
prison because you have to commit a
criminal act and then he needs a control
group so the control group is going to
be
you're a professor you've got students
use the students and he was running out
of people to put in the control group i
mean he even used himself as one of the
people so anyways running through this
control group and having a look at all
of the people that run it and he notices
this person's got no activation when
they're going through and he goes holy
[ __ ] this is the brain of a psychopath
in the control group i found a
psychopath in here i need to go and
contact him
it turned out to be him
turned out to be the professor himself
he discovered that he was a psychopath
whilst doing a study on psychopaths and
then he said actually you know what it
all makes sense now because when people
come around to my house and they're
eating my food
i think who the [ __ ] are all of these
people in my house eating my food why
are they here and they interviewed his
kids they asked his kids and they said
what is it like you know is there
anything unique about dad he said well
yeah dad
he doesn't smile that much around us and
he's not very warm he's not very loving
and blah blah blah but the point being
that you can have the biological
determinants of being a psychopath and
it not manifest this was a fully
functioning guy wife kids career
didn't smile much wasn't happy when
people ate his food but like broadly
fine but he had
essentially the same
raw materials as the person that was
murder in jail so what was what's the
determination how do they what are they
looking for when they find out that he's
a whole big long checklist it might even
be available online i'm not sure but
big long checklist of things that you
need to go through a bunch of questions
that you answer and they go through this
diagnosis but in order to breach the
threshold of clinically being diagnosed
as a psychopath you have to have used it
to commit crimes so this meant that
although this particular professor had
all of the raw ingredients and it looked
like he was psychopathic
by the what is it the dns what's that
thing the diagnostic statistical manual
dsm uh the dsm wouldn't have categorized
him as a as a psychopath very
interesting that is very interesting so
this guy
did they contact his spouse
well i think he was it was him doing the
study right so i guess he contacted his
spouse did he ask his spouse like him
what's wrong with me
[ __ ] knows why do you like me
perhaps but then you also have to think
the fact that psychopaths tend to be
pretty effective in the world right so
someone that has
very outgoing traits they're super
self-assured you know you have a
narcissism as well as as long as it's
not uh vulnerable narcissism there's two
types grandiose narcissism and
vulnerable narcissism what's the
difference so grandiose narcissists are
the ones who genuinely believe that they
are better than everybody else they are
constantly proving this to everyone
vulnerable narcissists manifest their
narcissism in a similar way but it's to
try and hide the fact that deep down
they don't believe that they're anything
so
both types of narcissism will manifest
in a similar sort of way
both of them will be out there but one
person is desperately seeking approval
and needs people to tell them that
they've done well and the other one
doesn't they're just going to continue
believing no matter what reality brings
to them now the vulnerable narcissists
are actually really dangerous and the
reason for that is that if the world
doesn't give to them that which they
think
they're going to get very very angry and
aggressive because that taps into
something that maybe they're fearful
about that's deep down
that makes sense that makes sense where
a lot of people who have a
distorted perception of where they
should be in the world are angry at
others who are doing well
and if someone takes them down if
somebody was to take the piss out of
them the grandiose narcissist it would
just be water off a duck's back
yep yeah definitely grandiose narcissist
right he's not he's not got vulnerable
narcissism in him someone that's a
vulnerable narcissist everybody knows
that friend that just can't
not bring up the most recent brilliant
thing they've done but they know that if
they poked them a little bit too hard
that it would really really hurt that's
the vulnerable narcissist